Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
and ahhh,
just checking in on you.
Oh,
I'm just shout happy Turkey day to you.
you know,
stuffing and potatoes and pie and beer.
Cranberries in gravy and your cousin who's gay.
Um,
hey,
what's going on?
How are you?
Happy thanksgiving.
Happy not having to fucking go to work today.
Huh?
You around the table.
Are you sitting down yet?
Well,
if you haven't gone downstairs yet,
I got,
I got some advice for you.
Today is going to be a day.
I think that's going to be a lot of fucking arguments.
A lot of fucking arguments at the table,
right?
The big fucking election.
Some people wanted the guy with the eyebrows.
Some people wanted the fucking
with the pants suit.
Right?
Um,
this is what you gotta do.
See,
you're already going to have a fight,
right?
There's already going to be your older brother.
There's going to be this person,
there's going to be another,
per,
somebody going to say something,
right?
And you're going to be,
you're going to have a couple of wild fucking turkeys as you standing over
there.
You know,
eating a fucking appetizer or two.
It's is going to be getting on your nerves.
Maybe somebody fucking wife who won't shut the fuck up,
right?
Why the fuck did he marry her?
Maybe.
Maybe it's the husband,
Jesus Christ.
What is she doing with this guy?
All he does is fucking talk about himself.
Something's going to drive you up the fucking wall.
If it's not this,
it's going to be that this is,
this is the phrase,
this is a phrase that's going to save your day.
Okay?
Save the whole fucking thing.
Cause you're not going to change anybody's opinion.
All these fucking jerk off,
still yelling.
He hung well,
could you vote for Trump?
Well,
what the Fuck About Hillary?
You're not changing.
You're just gonna fucking yell at each other.
So here's the phrase she got to use to get through this fucking day.
All right?
Along with the alcohol or whatever drug you fucking want to use,
just fair enough.
You know?
Hey,
fair enough.
That's all I,
that's all you gotta do.
What'd you say?
Hey,
hey guys,
guys,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
Whatever.
You don't need to see them anymore right now,
if you're younger and you still live there,
that's kind of fucking tough.
I don't know what to tell you,
but if you've already moved out of the house,
why are you still arguing with these people?
Why are you still trying to change their fucking minds?
You're not going to change their minds.
All right?
I don't give a fuck.
If you majored in debating,
it's just stupid fucking school in the woods.
Whatever the fuck it is.
You did that.
Now you're coming back and now you think you know something and you think that
you fucking siblings want to hear it.
You know what?
They don't the same way.
You don't want to hear the way they fucking eat when they,
and they've had a couple,
two,
three,
right?
And all of a sudden the man,
everything just sounds like they're eating fucking mashed potatoes.
You
know,
you start hammering these murderers fucking thoughts,
you know?
Just fair enough.
Hey,
fair enough.
Whenever,
whenever.
Was that what you think is that?
Is that how you look at the world?
Hey,
God bless Ya.
Pass the fucking peas and carrots.
Fair enough.
You know,
and that's all you've got to do that eventually the meal's going to be over.
All right,
and you're going to get in your fucking car.
You're going to drive away
unless you stay in there for the weekend,
then you've got to go out to,
I don't know what you got an you got,
oh,
right.
You gotta get the fuck out of there.
Yeah.
Thanksgiving is a tick.
It's such a great day.
There's no pressure to get any gifts,
eating a bunch of great food.
All of that is tremendous.
Okay.
Unless,
unless you go into her fucking family's house or his family's house,
that's a weird one because you know,
you're used to all your family's food and thanksgiving.
You know how it's supposed to taste that you're going to go somewhere else.
It's going to taste a little bit different.
You know,
this is like a classic standup bit,
like here's how it usually is,
but when you're fucking blah,
blah,
it's a whole different story.
Right?
And you just got to suck it up and just be like,
you know,
worst case scenario,
this absolutely fucking sucks,
you know,
in which case,
fair enough.
You know,
you don't know how to cook.
Okay,
you're supposed to cook today.
You know,
it's,
it's like when it's somebody's birthday,
most people can't sing,
but God dammit,
you got to sing the song.
So they do the best they can.
Happy Birthday,
right?
They do what the fuck they can.
Well,
sometimes she got to take the,
the,
the same fucking theory of a tone deaf person singing happy birthday to you
because they love you.
Right?
You get,
you've got to apply that to food,
which is a motherfucker,
which brings it to how do I make it look like I ate this shit when I really
didn't?
Well,
oh Jesus,
I don't know how to do this one.
What you gotta do is you gotta fucking,
uh,
eager to engage in a lot of conversation as you just sort of fucking hitting the
plate with your fork a little bit as if you almost like,
you know,
that noise people make when they want someone to make a speech.
That annoying fucking thing.
You know?
Oh my God,
nothing fucking makes my goddamned blood boil.
Like when I'm in the middle of a fucking conversation at some kind of starts
hitting the glass with the fork and then for whatever social fucking reason I
have to now shut up.
You know?
Oh my God,
that gets me God.
But not today.
Not Today.
Everybody.
Hey,
fair enough.
somebody down,
somebody down the fucking street over there with a little little fucking scone
knocking against some glass.
You know,
I guess we all have to stop as adults.
We have to shut the fuck up,
right?
Like we're working for this asshole baby.
You know what?
Hey,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
You know,
he just fucking sit there.
Oh,
here we go.
good.
Oh,
here's a cliched what?
I'm thankful for speech.
Oh,
is that what you're thankful for?
You know,
I'm thankful for lady.
Every fucking word that comes out of your mouth is one less worry.
It was one word closer to the end of whatever the fuck it is you're saying.
You know,
that's when you know you're the passive aggressive movies is when someone's in
the middle of that is you.
You fucking as some,
he just kind of pointed.
Somebody pointed some a plate,
you know,
little fucking,
give me that bottle right there.
Still yammering on.
You know,
you know back in 1983 when we first saw this house,
right?
And you just sit in their butter and you fucking roll.
Oh,
is this mother fucker gonna go every goddamn year from 1983 hey,
you know what?
Fair enough.
Yeah.
I didn't want to wear this sweater.
Right?
He's fucking have these potatoes.
Instant these fucking potatoes in.
Hey,
fair enough.
you didn't,
you didn't have time to fucking cook real ones.
Maybe they ran out of,
of down the grows the last fuck at time they ever ran out of potatoes.
They never run out of potatoes in this country.
It's why somebody fucking Irish people over here,
right?
Fucking Irishmen,
they tapped out on their own country one fucking time and their whole history,
they run out of potatoes and everybody fucking jumped ship.
Right?
But not the real Irishman.
They're real Irish men and real ladies.
They fuck it stuck around.
I like these cowards that all move to fucking New Jersey.
Um,
but you know what a fair enough,
you know,
they wanted some potatoes.
This is one of these days people,
you know,
and if you're younger man,
you got to enjoy the holidays cause cause they're never going to get,
it doesn't get better than you know,
cause you don't know any better.
So the food tastes the way the fucking food is supposed to taste in your world.
Right.
Everyone who's supposed to be there as there,
you know?
So when you get older and you start expanding your fucking world and all of a
sudden you know Jesus Christ,
I mean you're sitting there with somebody you might've given me up,
me might be sitting at that fucking table being,
I don't even know if I'm with the right person right now.
What the fuck am I take?
You know what,
hey say what?
Be Fair enough.
I'm with somebody that I probably was never really in love with but didn't
realize what love was.
You know,
and now here I am
and all I gotta do is not getting in an argument for one fucking day.
I can do this right by Saturday I'm going to be out of this fucking relationship
and you know what?
Oh,
I'm going to be thankful then.
Yeah,
you bet your sweet fuck.
MMM.
Oh my God.
If it starts going into,
it starts going into politics.
You almost need like a referee during this period of us history to just
literally step in with one of those footlocker fucking athlete's foot rev
shirts,
blow of fucking whistle,
and just send the two people to opposite fucking Lazy Boys.
Let it go.
Let it Aa.
It's all she went home.
She went,
oh,
it's all okay.
She's not coming back.
I don't think she's got a third runner.
All right.
Sit down.
Sit Down Buddy.
Nobody's building a wall today.
Okay.
Just fucking relax.
Maybe it can be the peace maker.
Who knows who the fuck knows.
Um,
I'm actually very excited.
You wouldn't know it this year for Thanksgiving because I'm back in my house.
The kitchen is done.
Oh my God.
Fucking kitchen is unbelievable.
My lovely wife fucking freaked when she saw she wasn't looking at it.
You know,
she says like,
I just want to say it when it's done.
I want to see it when it's done.
I didn't,
I was peeking at the presence the whole time Rohan in my Christmas,
but I also had to make some,
he had to make sure that the ship was looking.
All right.
So,
uh,
she got to see it from basically a gutted kitchen to just Bam right there,
Fred or fucking brand new kitchen.
And uh,
it's absolutely gorgeous.
The people who built it.
You know what?
That's what I'm thankful for.
The people who fucking built it,
man.
It's like a,
I can't believe that that thing is in my house and I get to go in there and make
myself a little Lego way g this morning with some bacon and all that.
By the way,
I bought that fucking grill top.
I bought that little fucking griddle thing last night and uh,
Nias pissed at me,
sort of.
You wait,
I'm going to make a one grand slam breakfast.
Right?
And once you shut the fuck up,
a little bit of fucking Hash Browns,
fucking Bacon,
right?
Slide the bacon over and you cook the fucking eggs in the crease of the Bacon.
Nick.
Nobody can handle that.
I don't know why the fuck we have gone in town.
Him Obey all those fucking people down there.
If you want him to talk,
he just make them a grand slam breakfast with the eggs cooked in the grease from
the bank and just be like,
hey buddy,
not for nothing.
I don't know what people told you,
but this right here.
This is America.
Okay,
welcome.
She's got to answer a couple of questions here.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
It's early out here.
Give me a fucking break.
All right.
What do you want from me?
Okay.
You don't like the podcast?
Hey,
gets what?
Fair enough.
I get it.
There's plenty other podcasts and you,
you enjoy God.
All things.
Comedy,
wonderful podcast network.
Go check out our,
we should fear skeptic tank.
You know the Park Chrysler podcasts.
I don't know what the fucking names of Omar.
What am I?
What am I these but fucking encyclopedia podcasting over here.
Um,
yeah,
there's going to be a lot of arguments today and it'll be a victory if I'm,
you know,
if you don't get in,
what maybe it could be that person that keeps everybody out of it is everybody
starts screaming and yelling,
you know,
he's okay
fucking checks offended,
blah,
blah.
Well,
she's a fucking day and all that type of shit.
And you can be in the back like,
hey buddy,
just walk right in the middle of it.
Oh Man,
I want to see a compilation of youtube videos of the political fucking,
I almost said discourse.
That's probably the wrong fucking word.
Do you really tell me fucking words?
I know that.
I don't even know what the fuck they mean.
I just know what words they go with.
You know,
discourse goes with political,
political discourse.
You know,
you used the word or Nate when you're in a theater.
I don't know what it means.
I,
you know,
I remember,
I got a computer.
I can look at any,
fair enough.
I can look it up.
Why am I going to bore you guys with this shit?
Um,
so when he was,
I'm back at my house and,
uh,
one of the great things about being back at my house is when I get back to my
house.
Okay.
I get back to all my sports packages.
I got the fucking center ice package.
Not Bragging.
I'm thankful for it.
You know,
I have it.
You don't hate.
Fair enough.
Come on over.
All right.
I get the fucking NBA one.
I don't even know what it's called.
I just watched the Celtics.
To me it's a Celtics network.
I'll watch the first half yesterday.
We do all right against the fucking Brooklyn Nets.
You know,
I think it's cool.
They moved to Brooklyn,
that place when they were in New Jersey.
I was just sad.
I was just a sad fucking place,
you know,
maybe not for the devils,
but for the nets.
It was fucking sad.
You know?
Admit it.
New Jersey people you never had love for him.
You know,
then that's where like that foreign exchange student who never fucking went
home,
you know,
or whatever.
You adopted a kid cause you thought it was a good idea.
You know,
you sell,
what are these fucking style?
It's out here doing it.
Yeah.
I go,
I will do it.
Fuck it.
We'll take them on.
What did they have a duty?
You know,
you had some good years old,
Jason Kidd.
I'm sorry if I'm fucking knock in this halls around my mouth.
I've had this fucking cough for God damn.
I don't know,
like two fucking weeks,
you know,
cause my,
my,
my wife with the condition she's in,
she's fucking always hot,
so she's got the Goddamn ac going and it just dries out my throat.
I've never been someone I fucking hate air conditioning Ellis.
It's like 9,000 fucking degrees out.
Then I like it.
Other than that,
I don't like sleeping,
you know,
feeling like I'm camping in my goddamn house.
You know?
I like it.
Like,
you know,
nice fucking,
70 71 degrees.
I need a seven.
That first number's gotta be a seven.
Like the price is right.
You know,
let's see that Saturday,
right?
You start getting into the sixes.
I wake up the next day,
I'm stuffy.
I got a mind,
my throat's killing me.
I Dunno,
I'll tell you,
people speaking at killing me,
I've been a,
I'm starting to begin,
uh,
the building of my new hour and obviously having a kid's going to be a whole new
angle for me,
but the kid's not here yet,
so,
uh,
I just been up on stage just fucking throwing shit against the wall.
And last night I went up to like 12 minutes,
nothing from my other act and I just,
Jesus Christ,
you want to talk about just feeling like you have nothing just being punched out
and uh,
I actually have some leftover shit I could've probably done bought out.
I did.
All right.
I did it right.
Went down there with a friend of mine just fucking knocking out new shit.
We'll see.
We'll see my specials coming out in January,
so I'm hoping I have a very inspirational December.
Actually that's not true because I don't really,
I don't have any road gigs until February and uh,
oh,
do I have some fucking road gigs?
We're putting together one in fucking Charlotte and I know what you're thinking.
Like,
dude,
you just fucking there.
I'm going to be doing the club there because,
uh,
the following day I'm going to Duke Carolina.
Oh yeah,
go fuck yourselves.
I'm going to go see coach k at Duke.
Can't fucking wait.
It's going to be fucking crazy.
Absolutely.
Legendary,
legendary bucket list.
You know,
I gotta get my college.
Who fucking games go in here.
Your eyesight.
Indiana University,
Indiana Hoosiers.
Who by the way,
would they fucking lose to the other day like Indiana regional technical
something or other?
It's their first fucking win of any goddamn ranked team ever.
I really should know their name.
I apologize that I don't,
I saw my adopted college team,
Kansas.
Um,
I don't know if they won their tournament.
I was watching a little bit of that Wisconsin when I watched the,
uh,
the semifinals when Wisconsin beat a Georgetown and I missed the final,
which was Wisconsin versa,
UNC because I went out and I was doing my homework last night and uh,
but I'm a Jay Hawks Fan.
I don't even know why I always wanted to go to their fucking,
the field house,
whatever the fuck they call it.
That's a bucket list thing for me.
I went to an Indiana Hoosier game way back in the day when Bobby Knight was
still there,
the year Michigan State,
when the,
uh,
one,
the title early two thousands.
I went there and I sculpt a student ticket and I was so fucking excited than
when I got to the gate.
The guy's looking at me.
I make that point.
I was like fucking in my thirties and shit,
right?
So the guy's looking at me like,
dude,
you're not a student.
And I was,
I had nothing.
I just would come on
N***a.
Sorry,
kidding.
I remember when that came out of my mouth.
I was like going,
Oh fuck.
I'm not getting in.
Come on,
let's all you had.
You didn't go with them.
A graduate student or I got that Brad Pitt disease from that fucking movie he
did with Taraji p Henson.
Remember when he came out as an old baby?
I would tell you this story.
When I watched that movie,
how much I annoyed the woman in front of me.
There's a scene in there when this dude is trying to fuck this chick.
And the fucking old baby won't shut the fuck up.
And I forget what he said,
but the look on his face was basically like,
lady,
if you don't get that 80 year old baby,
the fuck out of here.
I swear to God,
I can't remember.
I was fucking crying,
laughing,
you know,
typical comedian.
It was supposed to be this really heavy emotional moment that's supposed to
bring tears and instead,
I don't know if you're a comedian,
it just,
it just makes you laugh your ass off.
Cause when I'm,
what am I going them let's fucking sit in their crime and it God damn mall.
I'll cry about that.
I'll cry then I'm in a mall.
I'm not going to fucking cry while in a mall watching a movie right now.
Maybe I should have.
Maybe that's what the fuck's wrong with me.
But anyways,
um,
so I'll be watching.
I'll be talking about the Bruin.
I watched,
I didn't watch the Bruins versa.
The fuck were we playing?
I know we've got Ottawa.
How do you watch your Goddamn game?
He can't remember who the fuck they played.
All I know is Ciara went down in the second period.
Yeah,
it was one to nothing.
There was one,
oh,
he played the blues,
my adoptive West Western Conference fucking team.
That's right.
It was one to one than it was to one us than to to them.
Right with Ciara went out.
That's what it started fucking going down.
Health ended up being far too nice fucking home loss.
You know,
it was great.
I fucking put it on the center ice package.
They were like Barilla.
Is that a nice fucking winning streak?
Yeah,
cause I'll freckles fucking put it on.
Um,
and he was,
what the fuck am I talking about here?
I gotta I gotta read a little bit.
There's a lot of advertising,
so I got to break this up this week.
Hey,
bring it up.
Bring it up.
Um,
all right.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Can anybody tell me how to pronounce this fucking thing?
Oh Shit.
Indochino Indochina,
Indochina,
all this existing read.
All right.
Aiden don't,
Chai is one of the largest made to measure men's brands.
They're making it easy for men to get great fitting,
high quality suits and shirts and an incredible price.
How does it work?
Visit [inaudible] dot com or drop by one of their nine North American show
rooms.
Well,
Geez,
that's pretty exclusive,
Huh?
Nine is 50 states pick from hundreds of fabrics and patterns.
Well,
it's just like you go to see Jimmy the gent.
You can go pick out a suit down the alley,
choose your customer customizations from the plow lapels to pleats to jacket
linings in more.
Submit your body measurements,
kickback,
ah,
fuck that.
Submit your body measurements and then they ask for your social security number.
Now they're not like that.
They do that in the United States of America,
not in Indochina.
Um,
kick back,
relax and get ready to step into the best,
most stylish suit you've ever in.
Just four
weeks this week,
my listeners can get any premium Indochino suit Indochino for just 389 bucks.
indochino.com when entering bar at checkout get 50% off the regular price for a
made to fucking measure premium suit.
Plus the shipping is free.
That's indochina.com Promo Code Burr I,N ,
d o,
c h,
I,N ,
O,
India,
November Delta,
Oscar,
Charlie Hotel India,
November oscar.com.
And don't China for any premium suit for just three 89 for free shipping and
don't chat.
I know also has amazing holiday deals right now.
Santa Claus is going to get a fucking suit that fat cut.
They lift up your beard so we can measure your neck,
your old brick,
um,
holiday deals right now on their shirts and pants and other products to,
you'll never have to worry about badly fitting suits or expensive tricks to
trips to the tailor.
Again,
get ready to look like 1 million bucks or at least 10 grand.
Who wouldn't take 10 grand?
All right,
you wouldn't know.
I haven't had a cigar and fucking weeks.
All right.
Legacy box off the most legendary piece of fucking ass out there.
Legacy box.
Uh,
when was the last time you watched your home movies?
If you're like most Americans,
there's a box in your closet of videotapes,
film reels and photos that don't get watched or take it out worse.
They're actually deteriorating.
Well,
it's scary.
That's good.
Now they got me scared.
Now I want to get this introducing legacy box,
a simple and affordable way to get your recorded moments digitally preserved on
DVD or a thumb drive.
Can I do a little aside here?
I think I speak for everyone.
When you have that porno you made with your girl that you don't know where it
is,
just make sure you look at this shit before you send it to these fucking people
are legacy box is going to take a whole nother meaning there.
All right.
Here's how it works.
Load,
no pun intended,
legacy box with your ultimate apes film pictures and audio recordings and send
it back.
Uh,
you'll get,
oh oh load leg.
I will send the fucking thing back.
You'll get him back in a couple of weeks on DVD or a convenient thumbdrive ready
to watch,
share and relive.
This is so perfect.
If nobody knows who the fuck you are.
I can't do this because I'd love to do this with all my old standup tapes,
but I know that they would end up on fucking youtube and I cannot have that.
All right.
Legacy box takes care of everything and provides updates at every step of the
process.
That's why over 250,000 families have used them.
The Huffington Post,
parents magazine,
USA Today and the view are all talking about legacy box.
That's because they're getting paid to.
Even Disney has trusted legacy box to digitize their media.
Oh,
speaking of a company that's got to make sure that if they don't send the wrong
porno over there,
that was fucking animals.
Good Lord.
Who knows what they with one of the courses and for a limited time,
go to legacy box.com/bar to get 40% 40% discount on your order,
on your order,
off your order.
You should say that's legacy
box.com/burr legacy box.com/ [inaudible] with everyone gathered for the
holidays.
Now is the perfect time to share all those old photos,
cassettes,
and home videos.
Go to legacy box.com/burn now to get 40% discount on your legacy box.
Alright,
why is every fucking company so different or difficult to pronounce?
All right,
this is CSO.
See,
so leave me alone.
All right.
CSO is a place for comedy.
They won't tell you how amazing they are,
but evidently I well see,
so is amazing.
See that?
You see that?
I just fucking,
I lived up to my commitment.
It's comedy for nerds by comedy nerds.
CSOS spelled s e.
E s o is the new ad free streaming service bringing you hilarious original
series,
handpicked classics,
weeks of Standup specials and more bingeable comedy.
Anytime,
anywhere at Theso.
They have weeks of standup specials they been in.
And I had my fucking specials cause I didn't get a fucking dime from you.
Every episode of SNL,
Holy Shit.
Ever including new episodes the day after they air the tonight show,
starring Jimmy Fallon,
the late and late night with Seth Meyers,
the day after air.
And they even have classics like 30 Rock and recreation.
Oh,
parks and recreation and saved by the bell.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
This is an amazing place.
Even British comedies like the original and the best as far as I'm concerned,
office with Ricky Jervais saw that dangerous guy who does the Emmys.
He's drinking a beer.
Oh,
what's going to happen?
He's back.
What's he going to do this time?
Probably what he did the first two times.
That's why you keep rehiring him.
Re-Hiring rehiring.
All right.
The entire Monty python catalog,
the it crowd and Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge.
Discover the next big,
big names in comedy and watch the icons before they make it big like Louis C k
what he had here.
Chelsea Peretti,
Amy fucking shit.
Bo Burnham and so many more.
That's fucking hilarious.
Those last three started like fucking 10 years after me and they're talking to
them like they're these old,
grizzled vets.
How fucking old.
My critically acclaimed originals and exclusive content like Harmon quests
created by comedian Dan Harmon.
Well,
that's very modest of apoe and funny as hell.
A variety show featuring convenience such as Jim Jefferies and Hannibal Buress.
If you're serious about comedy,
you gotta try CSO stream at any time.
All right,
we get it.
The fuck am I doing here?
CSO is ad you already said that,
but just three 99 a month.
Right now my listeners can try CSO for free for two months.
When you use the Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout,
can I use it to,
I want to see every fucking episode of SNL.
Um,
plus years of SNL,
CSOS to place,
but we could get it.
We get it.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com right now and sign up for two months with the
Promo Coper at checkout.
That's Seeso.
Dot.
Yeah.
Com Promo Code Bar.
All right,
I'll give you a break here for my fucking reading out loud.
Um,
so anyways,
I've been playing drums like a fucking lunatic.
Been playing two hours a day for almost every day.
I missed yesterday because that was the day before fucking thanksgiving.
We had to run around and go get some shit.
Oh,
I didn't mention,
yes.
So this year I'm not,
I'm not having,
we're not having Thanksgiving here despite the fact,
you know,
we have a brand new kitchen.
We are planning to fucking have people over.
And then what happened?
It'd be all of a sudden a couple of people dropped out,
everything went out the window,
and then we had to scramble.
Now we've got all this fucking food.
Uh,
but whatever.
I got the grill top coming out,
fucking cook it later.
Uh,
we're actually calling an audible and we're going over to some friend's house,
which is perfect,
you know,
because we're traveling the day of.
So most people aren't going to be on the fucking road.
They're already there,
you know,
already getting into an argument because they didn't listen to this podcast and
he didn't know enough to be like,
hey man,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
Hey,
is that what you think?
God bless you for thinking that you think that,
and I'm not going to change you from thinking that,
but I don't need to think what you think.
And you know what all I have to do is eat with you today.
That's it.
Then I'm going to walk into the fucking living room,
you know?
Well,
I'd go in there to watch the football game.
Oh fuck.
Are you watching the Westminster dog show instead of the football?
Hey,
hey,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
You'd like to watch a bunch of clean poodles prints and around,
you know,
I don't get it,
but you get it.
You've got here first,
whenever,
whatever.
You got a vagina,
you run things.
Even though you always say you don't.
Okay,
go ahead.
Do it.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Look at that giant float.
Remember?
Bullwinkle of course.
Of course I do.
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
we're going to a friend's house and all I have to do is just bring the fucking
liquor and I'm,
and I'm good to go.
Nia is bringing over a tray of fucking Mac and cheese and that's it.
And then we're going to go over there and we're going to eat and have a good
fucking time.
I'll fair enough my way through the whole fucking party.
I'll get my God damn car.
I drive home.
No leftovers,
no fucking munching away.
Putting out a ton of goddamn white,
you know.
Perfect.
Fucking perfect.
Um,
so anyways,
so I've been,
I've been,
uh,
playing drums like a fucking lunatics,
but yesterday,
you know,
I got all these nieces and nephews and shit.
I got to buy him some fucking toys and uh,
you know,
so I was out there buying,
just,
I don't know a bunch of Goddamn Shit and uh,
I dunno God,
the fucking people that go in Friday,
you know,
it's too late to tell you guys this,
but you know,
you know,
if you don't have money,
you got to go out on Friday,
right?
You got to get that 40% off that fucking thing.
That's not even going to be there.
And then you get in the store and everything else is regular price,
right?
You got to get out there.
You literally have to risk getting fucking trampled to go get the next goddamn
game.
Boy,
a flip phone,
whatever the fuck it is your kid wants,
you know,
next year,
why don't you like,
you know,
there's two ways you can,
there's three ways you can deal with black Friday.
Okay.
One.
All right.
Save up some fucking money,
you know,
by some less expensive gifts.
Shoplift,
you know,
shoplift on a day that isn't black Friday.
Or maybe you want to do it on black Friday because then you can fuck you got the
cover of everybody getting stampeded.
They're not going to realize,
you know,
you gotta Hibachi underneath you fucking,
there you go ladies.
This is what you do.
You buy some fucking maternity wear,
okay.
And then you put a fucking a bace underneath.
Oh my God.
You know,
how many months are you?
Holy Shit.
Is that an Audi right with,
that's the handle.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
okay.
So that's one way of doing it.
The second way is if you know you're going to go down there,
all right?
What you gotta do?
You gotta do a lot of squats.
Okay.
And I take a little bit of Jujitsu cause you know,
you know the fights go into the floor.
Okay.
And don't practice on those fucking rubber mats that they have in the Dojo goes.
All right?
You want to get on a nice fucking the linoleum floor.
Okay.
For.
So when you skip the hip and you try to fucking turn him over,
like it's going to be a different surface.
Now,
if you've been practicing on a,
on one of those AMF mats,
like all of a sudden you're on the floor,
you know it's going to you.
You might,
you know,
you might throw out your hip trying to slide on that thing.
All right?
I will definitely add some weights.
There's a lot of big girls,
a lot of big girls show up.
Big Girls show up on fucking black Friday.
All right?
There's a lot of weight there.
So maybe I'd take a little Taquito I'd learned how to use their fucking,
you know,
all that,
all that physics coming at you.
Is that the right word?
Whatever the fuck it is.
All that way.
You just got to have it pass right through.
You like water.
That's what they always say,
right?
In Asian culture,
you gotta be like water,
you know?
Oh,
is that what I gotta do?
I don't,
I do it.
I can never touch my fucking toes the way you're doing it right now.
I'm not like water.
Okay.
I'm like the cup that holds the fucking water.
So how about that?
Right.
I know water can drown you and I know that water can fucking,
you know,
takes the form of whatever shape it's poured into.
But would you like to meet a smash this fucking cup over your head?
Yeah,
I didn't think so.
So being a cup.
Okay.
Or a fucking Sausa also.
Okay,
I interrupted.
I'm sorry.
I,
you know what?
Hey,
hey.
Kung Fu master Jetta guy.
Hey,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
Have become a water.
No,
the fuck I gotta do.
What are you gonna do?
Huh?
What am I going to do?
Call a couple of fucking orders of food here.
Say Bend over at the waist.
Gradually stretch in my hand.
He says that,
what the fuck I'm supposed to do?
Dude,
it's your fucking world.
Whatever you want me to do here.
Okay.
There's that option.
And um,
I guess I said the three options.
You know what the third options could be?
You could just say,
I don't observe the fucking holidays.
You don't,
by the way,
shout out to all the Jewish people today.
You know,
they always get left out on Thanksgiving because of their religion.
They don't celebrate it.
You know what I mean?
They just stayed home.
I was trying to say that,
you know,
I said that to Nia yesterday.
Right.
And uh,
I kind of mind fucked her cause they said it really quick.
St Jewish people did not celebrate thanksgiving.
You know,
obviously it's Christmas,
but you know,
it's the holidays,
you know,
if you're not Jewish,
like you have a vague understanding of everybody else's fucking religion.
Right.
You know,
there's a day,
you know,
there's a couple of hollow with Jewish people,
there's a couple of day offs we get because of their religion in September.
All right?
Or at least days we don't have to try as hard.
And then there's a day they eat Chinese food,
which is I believe Christmas or is it,
I think it's Christmas,
right?
I don't know what the fuck they do on new years.
Nobody fucking knows.
So if you're not Jewish,
she can throw shit out like that.
So I just throw out to near go and like,
uh,
we were in the grocery store.
I said,
you know what,
that's take time to give thanks.
You know,
and pray for all those Jewish people that don't celebrate Thanksgiving and then
she just goes,
fat isn't remotely true or something like she was trying to do with math in her
head.
I forget what the fuck she said and I died laughing.
I was like,
you had zero confidence in that right now.
And then she thought about it.
She goes,
no,
they sense a fuss about fucking give it thanks.
Everybody celebrates it,
right?
Except for Isis
and the terrorists.
Listen,
listen.
Do you guys have a thanksgiving?
What do you guys give?
Thanks for,
Huh?
I can't go down that fucking road.
It's going to be too God damn politically incorrect.
That's something late night at a comedy club you could do,
but not this day and age.
We're all of a sudden then somebody takes this clip and uploads it to fucking
drug soccer mom@fourintheafternoon.org and all of a sudden I find that fucking
in Fab.
Shut up.
Yeah.
Just drink your way to menopause lady.
All right.
On a know Aa ladies,
ladies.
Yeah,
fair enough.
Fair a fuck enough.
Oh,
you know,
dash you're a dancer and plants there and fixing.
Do you know the capital records building already had their fucking Christmas
tree up before thanksgiving?
I don't know what the fuck they're doing over there.
There's just,
there's something wrong about that.
You know what about Tommy fucking Turkey?
It was weird this year when I was in the grocery store and we were getting our
fucking,
all these food for this party evidently would not have enough.
Um,
for the first time ever,
I actually looked at a package at Turkey necks and I was like,
I'd eat that shit.
You know what I mean?
It's decent meat.
What do you,
how do you guys,
do you guys prepare your,
your,
uh,
Turkey necks?
Use it for a stew.
Fuck.
Alright,
here we go.
Let's read a couple more of these that I'm going to get on the fucking treadmill
for today.
You know,
that's another good thing you can do in the morning time,
right?
Get on a fucking treadmill,
knock out a good half hour or whatever,
you know,
just kill the apps that you're gonna eat today.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's read the last of these advertisements here.
Oh,
by the way,
thank you for all the well wishes about me and a d in our impending parenthood.
Uh,
it was very nice of you.
people said a lot of Nice Shit and that doesn't happen a lot on social media,
so thank you very much.
All right.
Oh,
here we go.
Everybody.
Oh,
here we fucking go.
It's our old friends were giving thanks to one of my favorite re-advertising
reads of all time.
Right up there with Sherry's berries.
Everybody who is it?
Eh,
zip.
Good ZipRecruiter.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
If you find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job to all the top job sites and now you can with
ziprecruiter.com you can post your job to 100 plus jobs.
Job Sites,
including social media networks like the Facebook,
like the Twitter,
all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll into all zip
up.
Um,
probably just woke up the neighbors with that one.
A five.
Okay.
What?
They're easy to use.
Interface.
No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Do you think isis uses this quickly?
Screen candidates rate them and hire the right person fast.
Does this person looked like they'd strap some explosives to themselves?
I know they kind of still got a little bit of Christmas in their eye.
All right,
swipe left.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter
has been used by over 1 million businesses.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on Ziprecruiter,
ZipRecruiter for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's
ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time.
Try It for free@oldzip.com slash.
Verb.
Alright.
SEATGEEK everybody.
Oh Jesus.
Seatgeek does it geek in every seat.
Just like that poor bastard that went to the cubs game a long time ago with his
little fucking cassette tape.
You
know,
and he stood up with another fucking for others,
cubs fans,
but that God,
Paul had to hit him and then that fucking left fielder had to fucking pointed
that dude and everybody forgot about your shortstop and where's that guy?
Now you know that guy is,
that guy was actually the grizzly man and he got mauled to death in Alaska.
Thanks to you cub fan.
So I hope you enjoyed your fucking world series parade.
All right?
Okay.
Seek everybody,
everybody.
Everything about SeatGeek is designed to make life easier for sports fans and
music fans.
Siki does all the price comparisons for you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get the best possible deal.
Seatgeek does all the work.
You just sit back,
relax,
and have a fucking Turkey neck and you say time and money and seek keke wants to
help you get the most bang for your buck.
That's why every ticket on SeatGeek is given a grade value upgrade based on
value.
You'll immediately see any underpriced seats and be able to find the best deals
that fit your budget.
Best of all my listeners get $20 a $20 rebate off their first SeatGeek purchase.
I want to see Mac Davis Bay the bay,
but don't give up on me.
Um,
call to action.
Must read.
Fuck you was going to read it anyway.
Stuff.
Tell me what the fuck to do your can put in a capital letters.
What are you yelling at me
seeks run by the fucking bullies,
right?
Sit down you fucking Gig.
All Right,
to get your $20 off rebate on tickets,
download the SeatGeek APP.
Go to the settings tab.
Uh,
I fucking hate settings and click add a promo code.
Enter Promo Code Birth Seatgeek will send you $20 off.
After you've made your first ticket purchase.
Download the CPQ APP and enter Promo Code Bar today.
It's the worst thing an old guy like me can hear is I'm talking to somebody
younger and they just go,
okay,
go into your settings.
It's like,
I'll fuck you.
Go into the
bowels of this device and just start scrolling and then click on this and then
another window opens up and then scroll down to this.
And then do this and then do that.
And then in the end they're like,
okay,
did that change anything?
Uh,
no.
No it didn't.
Oh,
that's odd.
Okay,
let's try this.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Are we troubleshooting right now?
Yeah.
Am I talking to somebody in the Malaysian islands trying to troubleshoot my
fucking phone.
Okay.
I swear to God,
half of this shit.
I just want to fucking mail it back.
I'm telling you,
man,
we should've just quit in like 1995 1995 we had all the technology we need.
All right.
Cars had reared spoilers.
You know,
you had a VCR.
VCR was great.
BCI was great when you didn't know what DVD was when there was no youtube,
right.
People paid for porn.
It was a different time.
It really was.
You know,
that's what these fucking millennials are going to be nostalgic about.
Like lesser technology.
I have no idea.
I should talk,
you know,
I don't fucking know.
You know,
you know what I've been looking at lately.
It's cause I got the little one coming and I want to fucking keep playing drums
in the house.
So I was thinking about getting an electronic drum kit,
you know,
boil boy would sure be great if somebody hooked me up with electronic drum kit
that I could promote for free on my podcast.
Look at me working it.
Yeah.
Fucked.
And I'm gonna buy,
I'm gonna buy it because if it sucks,
I'm going to tell you if it sucks or on.
So I was looking at all these fucking,
um,
electronic drum kits and for my money,
Rolan makes the best ones.
They've always been ahead of everybody else.
So they got it.
This fucking new one that actually comes with a 22 inch bass drum that looks
like a real acoustic drum.
I don't know what the fuck's going on with it.
And I'm like,
holy fucking shit.
Look at that thing.
That's the one right there.
Put your headphones on.
All the wife hears is the sound of the sticks hitting the pads and all that.
That's fucking it right there.
They want fucking 12 grand for this thing.
Okay.
12 fucking grant.
Fuck that.
I'm going to wait like five years by that thing on Ebay for like 600 bucks.
MMM.
But anyways,
do you think I don't like about those electronic kits though?
Is you sound way better than you really are.
And then your ego starts going through the roof and you're just like,
how am I not in a band that already fucking made it?
And we all have Grammy's and gold records on the fucking wall.
And then one day,
much to his Chagrin,
you then go and you sit behind a real kid and you actually have to produce the
fucking sound
and you're like,
oh yeah,
that's right.
I'm going to stand up.
Comedian,
I almost forgot because I've been playing an electronic kit for so fucking long.
Um,
however though I did see a demonstration of the one,
it's the TD cave,
TD something rather 50 and then the,
with the 22 inch kick.
And um,
this is how crazy technologies as I just bitched about it and said it was,
you know,
it was good enough in 1995 when they didn't even have the mesh heads on the
fucking kits.
It was like hitting a Goddamn fucking brick.
Um,
you took all the fucking,
the whole rebound or the fucking stick,
not rebound.
The whole fucking shock of the stick hit that you took it right in your forum.
Um,
anyways,
this guy hits the fucking ride symbol.
This is how incredible the technology is.
And he just takes the tip of his finger like you would on a real symbol.
And he just touched it and it's the vibration gradually went away just like it
would on a real one.
I don't know how the fuck they did that.
He did it all over this symbol too.
Cause it used to be like a certain areas you had to hit the symbol and that
would give you the bell sound or a cow bell sound or you could choke it,
but only if you had it there.
Now you can just do it all over the symbol.
It's fucking amazing.
But 12 grand with the fuck.
Who's that for?
I'll tell you is going to buy one of those fucking things.
One of those Saudi Arabian fucking,
uh,
oil kids that,
that fucking load up that be 52 bomber and fly all their fucking supercars to
Britain for two months.
That's what you gotta do.
There's any oil kids listening to me right now.
You got to buy that $12,000 in Kit,
right?
And you got to have the same fucked up mirror finish that you got on your 12
Lamborghini.
You know,
that gold fucking finish.
That's,
that's so fucking fascinating to me.
You know what I mean?
That level of godliness,
like,
you know,
you want like you,
it runs the whole gamut when you go around the fucking world.
There's some people like when you go to Paris,
it's everything's fucking muted.
And then Bam,
the scar for the fucking hat,
the bag or the shoes,
but everything else is the background singers,
right?
And whatever that big fucking thing is,
that's the fucking diva to die.
The Diana Ross of your fucking outfit,
right?
And then you go to other areas,
you go to fucking Italy,
some places in the Middle East,
um,
Armenians,
right?
They're like,
fuck that.
What if we put a group together and everybody,
you got Diana Ross,
you gotta,
Rita,
all Davis,
they go all fucking diva.
It's a whole other fucking style and the level of confidence.
You have to have the pull that off.
I'll tell you right now,
you know,
can't pull that off.
You have to have a certain level of pigment in your skin to really pull off
flashy shit.
If you notice that Shin,
the pastry,
or you get to get up to my fucking ancestors,
you know what I mean?
The,
the,
the colors,
it gets real fucking limited.
Forget about when you're a fucking ginger.
I mean,
the amount that,
the fact that I actually have a red wind screen on my fucking,
like if there was a picture of me right now in my pajamas,
what's,
what's left of my red hair?
You guys watching me talking into a mic with a red fucking windscreen,
most of you would never listen to this podcast again.
You know what I mean?
But if I actually had some pigment,
you know,
I can be sitting here with gold frame glasses with a gold tooth and a gold
microphone.
And you'd be like,
that guy is the shit.
So there you can,
you know what?
Hey,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
You can pull it off.
I can't.
Alright,
that's the podcast for this week.
Hey,
happy Thanksgiving everybody.
And I'm thankful to each and every one of you that you listen to my dumb ass
every fucking Monday and Thursday.
All right?
Now don't get any into,
into any arguments.
All right?
You don't want to be that fucking person.
Just sit back and enjoy everybody else yelling over politics,
you know,
and then you could just be the cut in the background.
What about Joe by
Michael Dukakis,
Grover Cleveland,
whatever the fuck you want to yell out there.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a nice weekend.
You can't enjoy your goddamn Turkey and egg.
Fair enough.
Don't get in any arguments.
All right?
Or maybe a dope and,
uh,
let me know how fair enough worked out.
How long were you able,
how many drinks in,
we were able to stick with it before you finally lost your shit.
And I want to hear about the arguments.
All right.
Sentiment.
Okay.
Fuck you.
I'll see.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
you can see what I can
throw my faith to the
next
[inaudible]
Thanksgiving Day special Billy crocket.
There's a new one.
Betty Crocker.
Billy Crocker.
I liked it.
And I like to cook.
That's a good one.
Love your intensity when it comes to bringing something to the table on
Thanksgiving.
Absolutely.
No Pun intended.
It's,
it's really a no brainer.
Get good at making something and get to a point where your automatic oh,
he's talking about,
yeah,
like I was talking about a few weeks ago.
When thanksgiving comes around,
you got to have that dish that you just fucking can make and you throw down and
you take it to another level.
All right?
Everybody else should be doing the same thing.
And then the end,
that's the Thanksgiving meal.
Um,
so this guy goes,
yeah,
you should get a dish downs where your automatic,
how hard can it be?
A,
you'll,
you'll never bet you'll never been.
You've never been expected to step out of your skill set.
If you're baking breads,
no one will ever expect you to bring the cranberry sauce.
Uh,
what should go to this year?
What's Nias specialty?
What's my Goto this year?
How about the whole fucking meal
doing?
I'll tell you right now,
you guys think I'm a fucking one trick pony.
I can make you a Turkey dinner.
Was stuffing
mashed potatoes.
My gravy game is getting better.
I've got to work on my gravy game and I know that's crucial.
All right.
But my fucking ah,
my mashed potatoes,
not a fucking lump in all right enough.
Bottom to make you slat off the chair.
Um,
as they say in New Orleans,
that's been willing to x and I admitted my stuffing.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right dude,
you don't understand the recipes that I have access to all of my recipes.
Start with melt a stick of butter and a third,
a cup of Chris.
Go on a pan.
Okay.
So you know it's delicious.
Um,
yeah,
my stuffing.
MMM.
I don't,
I mashed potatoes or the shit,
but knee is African American,
so she likes more sweet potatoes.
So I don't,
I don't think they,
uh,
that side respects mashed potatoes the way they should.
Okay.
I feel like my potato,
my,
my United colors of Benetton,
whatever the fuck it is,
respect for,
for sweet potatoes and mash potatoes,
I think I'm a little more mature
than the lovely Nia.
Um,
what's Nia specialty?
Uh,
Nias great at everything.
She's one of those people that I,
I'll be out in the kitchen like there's nothing,
what the fuck?
I'm starving.
And she be like,
what do you,
this doesn't age.
She comes out there and exceed goals.
You've got a couple of things on her arms and I dunno,
I'm eating spaghetti or I don't know what the fuck I'm eaten.
She somehow just throws it all together or make some ridiculous Omelette.
MMM.
She's actually a,
a true cook.
I'm a little more robotic.
MMM.
I think I'm going to become a,
a great cook or a better cook.
The way I became a better comedian,
where at first I was a joke writer and I was trapped in my act and then I
learned how to Improv and she's kind of just watching her.
She kind of,
as she cooks,
she's tasting it and doing all that type of stuff where I just,
they said to leave it in 15 minutes,
it's been 15 minutes and I take it out.
MMM.
Um,
pies.
I kinda got the whole thing do from start to finish.
My,
uh,
my appetizer game is terrible.
In fact,
I don't even know if I know how to make
one.
I have no idea.
But do what?
I can make a pie from fucking scratch.
Okay.
I can look at you and tell you what all your fucking problems are as I'm making
the pie crust and not even look down once I can just feel the texture.
You know what I'm saying?
That's how many fucking Pi's I've made.
All right.
And I'll take debt pie someday and I'll bring it to your fucking house.
And I'll take a whole hunk of it just in,
I'll just shove it,
write down your throat in these nothing that you're going to be able to say
other than thank you for that experience.
All right.
As of shaking up the can of whipped cream to give you a facial
[inaudible]
is,
it
dies.
Hey,
what's up?
This is the Monday morning podcast.
A little excitement in my voice when I said that
kids
is,
you have to say,
I am excited.
Why am I excited?
Um,
I don't know.
I don't know why.
Maybe because it's Thanksgiving week and it's a week to give,
you know,
one,
two year.
Everybody has to sit down and think about why they're so lucky.
I just shut the fuck up and give me some goddamn Turkey.
Keep that part of the fucking Thanksgiving where else and something's going to
give me a speech.
Like I,
I like,
I don't appreciate what I got,
you know,
just shut up.
Um,
yeah.
So thanksgiving,
thanksgiving week and it has a week to give.
Thanks.
I am thankful.
I'm just fucking around and um,
I'm making a Turkey and a with some stuffing and I had the most insane recipe
for stuffing that none of you will be getting during this podcast because it's a
secret family recipe.
Okay.
So you have to be part of my family or be bang and me and catch me at a moment
of weakness.
He'll be a great thing of a girl did that you're just laying on your back.
She's riding here and then somehow she,
she's so,
she's so good and bad.
She gets you to give away a secret family recipe.
You're like,
ah,
yeah,
yeah.
27 pieces of white bread.
What holds it together?
It's the egg.
Um,
alright.
I'm literally sitting in my fucking car and my,
my Toyota Prius in a,
in a parking lot outside.
Um,
my,
my little offices that I have out here in a little production offices is like
inch my way along on my little unerring pilot,
I'm getting ready to shoot a non airing pilot,
which basically means you shoot it and then they look at it and they go,
either we like it and then we want to reshoot it or they go,
yeah,
that's why a wasn't [inaudible] cause that's sucks.
So,
um,
yeah,
that's what I got going on in my fucking life.
This creepy go.
This
guy just pulled up next to me and I'm really worried that he's going to fucking,
they put up my windows here in Erie that he's going to fucking bump his door and
then my car,
which he didn't and he's kind of,
Oh,
I wouldn't say he's really fat.
Definitely has a foreman grill.
Yeah.
That's nice.
Fucking love handle.
Just hit my side view mirror.
All right.
Oh,
you know a lot of people last week broke my balls.
Um,
and an email kind of way going in like,
you know,
cause I thought that guy rear ended me and they'll go,
what did you go check?
You know,
what are you the most trusting guy in la?
You don't fuck,
I got a bunch of shit like that.
And it's,
and it's basically,
cause I figured out what it was told you my fucking car happened today.
It was all on electric and then the car kicks over and for some reason it gives
you a little push.
It,
it makes the car lurch forward.
I'm really not selling hybrids on these please fucking podcast cause I make them
sound like they suck.
They're actually there on the damn good cars.
But anyways,
um,
it is quick affects given I like the fuck I'm talking about and my fingers smell
like an orange because I just ate one.
Um,
yes,
it's Monday morning podcast.
I do one of these once a week every Monday to give people something to laugh
about as they sit in their cubicles as a drive or fucking run on a treadmill.
And if you have any questions that you want me to answer,
just email me at bill at [inaudible] dot com or my space.
Me and uh,
yeah,
if you have any questions,
I don't care how ridiculous it is.
I will answer the question like this.
Here's a,
here's a,
here's a nice question.
A question number one.
Um,
hey bill,
I've been a huge fan of yours since you barely,
since you were barely beaten by Ruben,
started on American idol.
Have you ever thought about giving it another shot?
Um,
you know what,
my time on American idol,
I don't regret any of it.
I had a,
I had a great time.
You know,
some of the numbers that they had is perform like Muskrat love and tie a yellow
ribbon that,
you know,
I wouldn't trade that for the world,
but you know,
I've moved on and I feel so much,
you know,
I got my sexuality's out there.
Is it,
did I dream that it wasn't on the cover of people magazine?
It's fucker standing.
I looked like clay Aiken is what he's basically saying.
The sad thing is that's not the first time I've heard it.
Okay.
Um,
you know what you did,
you just expose yourself for actually watching that fucking show.
What do you think about that?
Huh?
I don't need this shit.
You know,
people supposed to ask me questions.
You're not supposed to make me feel bad about myself.
Like,
Hey,
you look like the gay guy who lost.
We that could've been it looked like a gay guy won,
you know,
always do.
So we'd be in jail.
It's sucking.
No,
I'm kidding.
Um,
but they do that.
They definitely do that.
You know,
I learned from some of my gay friends that a lot of them actually don't engage
in anal.
It just like,
no,
it hurts.
I'm like,
so what do you do when evidently they just sort of sit around blowing each
other?
Yeah.
So
let's get to question number two.
Let me see,
maybe this one will be a little nicer.
Bill,
in my opinion,
all negative,
bitter people,
all women.
I'm such a moron.
I can't even read here.
Fill in my opinion,
all negative bitter people think everybody,
everybody are always out to fuck them.
Maybe that's why you have such a handle on conspiracy theory.
Am I wrong?
It's another guy kind of shitting on me,
you know,
for Thanksgiving week.
You know,
you'd think that'd be some more thankful fucking questions.
How do you ask a thankful question?
I just can't.
How did you become such a great person?
So thankful question.
First of all,
if you're going to trash me,
can you try to actually work out the grammar so you don't look like a moron?
In my opinion?
All negative bitter people think everybody are always out to get to fuck them.
All right.
In my opinion,
people who don't use capitals or punctuation or fucking morons.
Um,
all right,
let me reread this so it actually makes sense.
Okay.
And this guy's opinion,
of course he has to let me know.
This is opinion in case I thought he had a staff of writers who write his
fucking emails.
Um,
okay.
All negative bitter people think about,
think everybody is what does this all negative,
bitter people think?
Everybody
it gives you for,
you've got this thing so fucked up.
I can't even read it right here.
Oh,
negative,
bitter people think everybody.
Everybody's out to get them out to fuck them.
How about that?
Does that make sense?
Maybe that's why you're such a handle on conspiracy theory.
Am I wrong?
Uh,
yes.
Yes.
You around.
Um,
I'm not a better person.
I'm definitely a,
I definitely negative,
but,
um,
I don't think people are out to fuck me.
Like I don't walk into a bakery and go,
can I get a cupcake?
And when they forget to give me a Napkin,
I don't go.
You see,
I knew it man.
Um,
and I think conspiracy theory gets a bad rep.
Conspiracy theory gets trashed constantly by people who never look into
conspiracy theory.
You know what I mean?
All they do is they see one guy on the news who goes visit guy living in the
moon,
and they're like,
that's right there.
That's conspiracy theory.
That's what they,
that's what they all think.
They're,
they all have conspiracy theories like that,
you know,
I don't,
I mean,
I guess,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to do for you.
You have to look at some of the conspiracies that I'm into and then make your
judgment from there.
If you think,
I don't know,
I can't judge myself,
but I mean if you read about the Federal Reserve,
if you ever sit down and do the math on your mortgage in,
realize that the bank turns you into an indentured servants for fucking 30
years.
You know?
Do you ever think about that shit?
Do the math in your mortgage.
I have a three of $50,000 fucking loan.
If I take 30 years to pay it back,
I paid,
I give them $766,000 plus the 80 grand I put down on it.
So now what are we up to?
$840,000 so at the end of my mortgage going to be one of those morons go.
Yeah,
no,
they fucking place doubled in value.
I paid three 50 now you didn't stupid.
You paid eight 50 you basically made about 800 bucks in 30 years and now you're
68 what are you going to do?
Take up water skiing,
it's over.
It's fucking over.
You know,
and at that point they've devalued the dollar because they keep printing it with
no gold behind it,
which causes inflation.
Now you can't afford the property tax,
so you have to sell it.
You move out and they get another 35 year old to move in.
Ben Dover,
drop his pants and it gets fucked in the ass for 30 years.
And uh,
yes,
I think that that is a,
I think that that's bullshit,
you know?
Does that mean I'm fucking nuts?
I probably coming off his nut.
I don't know.
I'm just saying,
I think my by conspiracy theories or thought out like I feel whatever they're
doing to dogs,
they're going to be doing to us in 10 years.
All right.
And I don't know if you've looked around,
but dogs are basically neutered with microchips in shelters waiting to be
rescued.
That's what a fucking dog is.
Now when you were kids,
remember the freedom dodge used to have,
I mean,
seeing two dogs fucking in public was a part of people's childhood and now you
know,
they can't,
they can't even fuck anymore because they,
they,
they've been neutered and uh,
that's what I think they got to do with us.
Microchips chips can deal with the population.
They're going to get bigger and start fixing people.
Okay.
And if I was on right wing radio,
I'd be like,
I'm to exactly what they need out.
Right.
Um,
that made no sense and I apologize.
All right,
question number two,
Bill.
Uh,
are you worried about becoming too famous?
Well,
if 40 years of age,
I'm worried about not becoming famous because I've invested a lot of time into
this.
I actually have a cool level of notoriety.
Um,
I know what you mean.
I think those people who are two famous,
I think they seek it out.
I really don't think the Paparazzi is like the CIA and they have the ability to
figure out when you're going to go to Starbucks without your panties on.
I think there's,
there's a little fucking surf.
And turf action going on there.
You know,
there's a little bit of the artist playing up,
you know,
don't they call their publicist?
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I couldn't fucking,
I mean,
I don't know.
It's just,
there's just too many famous fucking people.
There's too many places where you can go.
Like,
how do they know you're coming from getting off the airplane at the airport?
You ever seen that?
What happens?
Just the guy at the sky cap just happen to know somebody in the Paparazzi.
Does somebody nodding right now as if they know and as if they've done it.
Maybe.
Okay,
maybe that happens.
Maybe that happens a little bit,
but you know what I mean?
All I know is I look at a guy like Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez and five years
ago when they were dating each other,
j Lo,
what do they call it?
Ben Flow.
Yeah.
Uh,
Jay [inaudible],
what the fuck did they cut?
Benefit.
Benefit,
right?
Remember that you could not get away from it.
And they were everywhere.
And I was like,
either they have to kill themselves or I do because this can't continue to
happen.
Right.
And then they broke up with each other and then all of a sudden nobody gives a
shit about them anymore.
It's like I get when to famous people date that Paparazzi swarm all over you.
But both of them broke up and then married other famous people.
Yeah,
he married a Jennifer Garner and she married a
debt debt.
Creepy looking guy.
Who Was it?
Julio Iglesias.
She married.
Yeah,
he looks like he looks like the Lion Tamer.
It's not,
not the blonde haired one.
The uh,
who is oh the lion tamers Cisco and neighbors
fucker.
Their name.
Who those guys.
He looked like the one that got grabbed by the throat.
Yeah,
Chris Catan looking one.
Chris Catan.
You know,
if they ever do the fucking uh,
Siegfried and Roy story,
Chris Catan has to play Roy.
And that's also,
that's a media part.
Maybe the blond guy,
his immediate park because he gets to cry at his hospital bed,
like Fonz a rally when Richie Cunningham wiped out on his motorcycle.
Remember that cause if you need him I do is fucking leather jacket was going in
and out because Henry Michael was crying.
Um,
okay.
Let me get back to the question.
Are you worried about becoming too famous?
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
there's a certain level you don't want to go beyond,
you know what I mean?
Like those guys,
like whenever I see like celebrity houses,
they're like,
and he has his own tennis court,
his own fucking movie theater and people are like,
oh my God,
that's awesome.
And it's like,
they never really think that he has his own tennis court in his own movie
theater because he kind of has to because he can't go,
he can't get,
can't go anywhere.
So yeah,
I wouldn't want to get to that level of fan.
I would like Steve Buscemi fame flood time.
You saw him and ogs magazine,
US magazine.
I was just thinking,
I know all those whores always wear uggs.
US magazine.
It was the last time you saw him in US magazine,
you know,
wearing a pair of uggs,
going to get some coffee.
No one gives a shit what he's doing.
So I think you really control it.
I think your publicist,
you know,
I think as long as you're not brought up on a murder charge or uh,
you're not drinking and drugging and just making a spectacle yourself.
Yeah.
I don't,
they think of all the famous fucking people out there who just kind of just live
their life,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
I never seen,
you know,
Anthony Hopkins nutsack as he stepped out of Alexis.
You know what I mean?
You just,
the guy wears underwear and he's not doing drugs.
I mean,
that's basically it.
That's how you stay out of the papers.
Just don't do.
Interesting.
Thanks.
Okay,
well I guess that would suck up,
but you're famous so you're getting a level pussy.
That's all a trade off.
All right.
Um,
let's get over to overrated,
underrated.
Um,
for those of you who are new to my podcast,
because I just keep getting new listeners every week,
um,
we do this one part it where people send me in their list of shit that they
think is overhead,
overhead,
overrated and shit that is underrated and their reasons why.
And I actually am contributing this week rather than letting my listeners do all
the work.
Um,
I would say,
uh,
overrated,
the l shaped couch.
I'm actually right now trying to buy some furniture and uh,
I've had an l shaped couch before and I didn't realize they suck.
Basically they suck because there's no place to put the TV when you have people
on an l shaped couch because you got people they're like,
and then not perpendicular.
Perpendicular is sight lines are perpendicular.
So where the fuck do you put it?
Somebody has got to turn their neck and the next going to end up hurting.
And not to mention it's a very,
you know,
as people start drinking,
people sightlines start crossing and that's what,
that's how guys get in the fight.
You know,
you stare in another guy too long,
you think somebody looking at you and he says what the fucking Jack Daniels is
telling you,
you know.
And next thing you know,
you fucking crash land on the,
on your Ikea coffee table.
It's,
you know,
where it is.
The guy you ended up getting to a fight with the guy that your friend brings
that you don't even fucking know any,
any consent because he doesn't know anybody.
He sits as far away from everybody as possible and thinking that that's the,
uh,
the submissive thing to do.
But it's actually an Alpha male move.
Cause now he's looking across everybody's lines.
Sightlines who at face forward.
So discovery channel thing.
So fuck l shaped couches,
what you want as a couch and then you want,
you want another one of those other couches,
the king with the,
uh,
with the thing that you put your big square thing that you put your feet on.
That's what the fuck you want.
You don't want to,
you don't want to lazy bully.
The lazy boys are also overrated.
They're not comfortable.
They're not,
they suck.
And all those airplanes now that have lazy boy FirstClass each and like,
oh wow.
Yeah that would be great.
He could sleep the whole flight just,
you know,
one night go downstairs to your recliner and spent fucking eight hours in that
thing and let me know how comfortable in this.
Um,
alright,
underrated,
underrated.
You know what?
I actually,
when I've got some fast food for a bunch of people the other night and somebody
actually took the time,
you know,
on the fast flu foods,
so to,
they actually push down the tab to let me know which one was cola,
which one was diet and who,
you know,
who had other,
and for some reason it's such a nice thing for someone to do and nobody does it.
So fast.
Food technicians who actually take the time to push that fucking thing down is,
uh,
is really underrated and I think they deserve a race.
Um,
all right,
those are mine for fun,
for the weaker.
Right.
And here's some more people,
uh,
overrated friends,
the TV show,
uh,
is that overrated?
I've never really fun.
Okay.
And friends is overrated,
right?
I hated the show when it was on and I can't believe that it's considered good
enough to be syndicated nationally and aired every day.
I think this show mostly appeal to women as,
I don't know,
a single guy that was waiting on the edge of,
of their couches for the new episode.
Yeah.
That's one of those chicks shows,
there's no reason.
And um,
I'm sure David Schwimmer isn't really like that in real life,
but,
uh,
I just knew every time they would do a montage of,
of the friends,
you know,
live their little episodes.
He always had to be getting really excited and jumping up and down like a chick
doing like a false settle,
you know,
lean on when chicks like something's going to be exciting and they jump up and
down and clap their hands.
I'm,
or maybe at least TV chicks,
he would always be doing that.
Ooh.
And it just,
it just made as a guy,
if you just wanted to fucking,
he just want to,
you know,
you just want something bad to happen to them.
That's what I was always waiting for.
I just want to see the episode where Ross got the shit kicked out of him.
You know,
I remember one time going and watch the Brady Bunch and uh,
you know,
what's his face?
Bobby did something to,
to Greg,
and somehow Greg had orange hair and he actually looked like he was mad enough
that he was going to beat the shit out of Bobby.
And Bobby was hiding behind Florence Henderson and uh,
you know,
I remember being a little kid really wanting to see Bobby get the shit kicked
out of him.
Like I wanted that.
I really wanted to see it happen.
And it's probably why,
you know,
30 years later I'm watching the UFC.
I mean,
that's the storyline that I want.
You know,
I just thought about that was Greg was actually sort of bang and Florence
Henderson.
Right?
Then I wonder if Bobby knew
Mike Lucan land like this evidently lives in Utah.
I don't even know why.
I fucking know that.
Um,
all right.
Underrated.
Somebody said radio hit 10.
Some of you guys,
I don't know about these suggests.
Is Radiohead really underrated,
critically acclaimed.
Everybody like talking about Austin there.
All right.
This man has been around for a very long time.
Is yet to put out an album that would be below three stars on your four star
scale system.
Whenever I try to talk to people about them or even to get a group of people to
go see them play live.
Nobody is interested at all.
And No,
I don't talk about radio head all the time.
The media barely ever talks about the band and when they do,
they only talk about OK computer,
the band's third album.
This band deserves a lot more attention and praise from people as they are one
of the best bands ever formed.
Um,
I got it.
Okay.
And I know what you saying.
Well this is what you gotta look at.
You know,
no matter how good your band is,
it's never going to get the attention of some girl with no panties on or with
the titties hanging out.
I mean,
I dunno,
I'll probably speaking out of turn here because I don't have a vagina,
but it really just seems like women realize this and they're forever showing
their fucking ass and things
like,
even like girls who will like respectable.
It's like,
no,
I'm not doing this.
I'm not doing booty videos and blah,
blah blah blah.
And then they finally get on like a sitcom or something and the first spread
they do.
You know what I'm saying?
They got on like the little coochie cutters to fucking who has hanging out.
You know,
they got two fingers,
the index and middle finger over both nipples with their mouse half open.
Like,
oh does somebody want their cock sock?
They always do like that,
that photo shoot,
you know,
laying down completely naked and everything.
Somehow you don't quite see their ass crack and there's no nipple but you
basically,
you basically see their entire body except for the ass crack and some nipples.
Other than that you've seen every piece of flesh that's on them.
And uh,
you know,
they always do that and I dunno,
that's what I don't understand why I'm always bitching about that type of shit.
Talking about,
Oh,
you're treating us like sex objects.
It's like fuck you every,
every time your career is in trouble.
You put on a pair of fuck me pumps and you bend over a couch and then they go
the new sizzling pictures of fucking
who's one of these girls I saw do well,
getting back to friends,
Jennifer Anniston and my,
but she did that on rolling stone.
You know,
one of the highest selling things ever.
I think women should embrace being treated as sex objects.
You know what,
what do,
what do you want to be?
We're not.
What do you want to be known for being like a meteorologist?
Sometimes I should just stop talking because that just keep going and then it
just get dumber and dumber.
Um,
I think that even answer that question.
All right.
Uh,
we got else,
we've got a couple of other here,
couple others here.
This guy said last week you mentioned voting for Ron Paul because of the Federal
Reserve.
Um,
now that's the wrong one.
Okay.
Okay,
Bill,
here's a question.
Do you have a sketch comedy show in the works also,
now that Randy courts coture is out and I'm not gonna say his name.
What are your thoughts on Brock Lesnar versus the door?
And Mac.
I like I lingo.
Who Do you think of when,
um,
I have no fucking idea.
I gotta be honest with you.
I have no idea.
I just know Brock Lesnar was one of the biggest human beings I've ever seen his
one of his texts,
you know,
it's,
it's like just the Pec muscle is the thickness of my entire torso and the size,
like from my neck down to my waist.
So I don't know.
Doesn't he have like a fucking tattoo right between his pecs?
It's like a dagger.
It's either a dagger or one of those Ben Franklin quill pens.
I don't know what it is.
I have no idea.
I don't know who the fuck's gonna win it,
to be honest with you.
I've been doing a lot of standup in those fights.
Always come on Saturday nights.
I ordered the NHL package,
so now my cable bill is like fucking 200 bucks a month.
And uh,
you know what I hate?
I hate whenever you're the guy hosting the fight,
right?
And you're like that guy.
No,
I don't want to fight six other guys to come over.
Everybody tosses me fucking whatever,
10,
15 bucks.
And then,
you know,
the fight cost me,
10,
15,
whatever.
What happens?
Everybody throws,
you crumpled up 20s,
the end of the night you stuff it in your pocket and you go out and you spend it
on gumballs and fucking raisins and you know,
toilet paper and then the bill comes along.
It's like you never had that money.
I don't know why.
Why can't you just be thankful during the week of Thanksgiving that you got some
fleet toilet paper?
Wow.
That is the worst fucking shirt I've ever seen.
Picture a lime Green Charlie Brown shirt except as did the zigzag line is just
straight and for some weird reason you're wearing it with incidents,
colo style.
And for some reason you're wearing black slacks with it.
And then you ran across the parking lot and sort of a run walk on the balls of
your feet.
Like how Walter Peyton used to,
maybe he's trying to avoid major injury just like him.
Um,
anyways,
let me wrap up this fucking podcast cause I got some Chia to you have to go do
and I go back into the building and no ma'am.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
what are we gonna do?
let's hype type what I got coming.
Oh,
first of all,
you know,
I forgot to do with fucking thing I've got to do at the top of this podcast I
want is,
I wanted to thank Joe Perry from Aerosmith for calling in a uninformed is the
radio show I do with Joe to Rosa.
We had a great time interviewing him and he was obviously our biggest and
coolest guests we've ever had.
Totally down to earth.
And uh,
you know,
I don't know.
It's pretty fucking awesome to get to interview somebody who you've been
listening to for the last 30 years,
you know,
so that's what I'm thankful for this week against him.
And,
and uh,
I would also be thankful if people come out to my show at Caroline's the first
weekend in December,
let's see,
706 fifth,
fourth,
December 4th through the seventh.
I'll be at Caroline's comedy club on Broadway.
The last stop on the uninformed tour with me and Joe de Rosa with special
guests,
Harris Stanton who will be hosting and a,
and that's it.
Happy Thanksgiving to everybody.
Thank you for sending in the questions.
Oh,
if you guys could do me a favor,
if you can go to my website,
if you're not on it right now,
just go to [inaudible] dot com if you scroll down on the right hand side,
you can actually see where you can sign up for my email list just because a lot
of times they send out bulletins about being in Seattle on my space and they
ended up going to people who live in Albuquerque.
If you,
if you're on my website,
you literally just sign up on the,
uh,
the city that's nearest you.
So that way you don't have to get a fucking email from me every two weeks.
I just don't want to be spamming people or any of that shit.
So if you sign up on my website,
you'll only get bulletins from me when I'm playing in your area.
Or if I'm going to be on TV,
basically if it's something that you can either see,
watch here or go to is the only time you'll get emails.
All right.
So that is it.
Thank you for listening to the podcast.
I apologize the last couple of weeks of feeling like these things have been a
little bit lame because I've been,
uh,
I've been really busy trying to do,
do some shit out here and,
um,
and that's it.
So what am I going next weekend?
Next week is going to be out to do a Sunday night.
Next week.
There will be a Sunday night podcast and,
um,
I'll,
I'll be better rested for it.
All right.
But I appreciate you guys sending them the questions and I'll just keep saying
the same thing over and over again for another 18 minutes by don't hang up.
All right.
So you guys all have a good Thanksgiving and,
uh,
you know,
and just try to remember what you have to be thankful for.
All right,
I'll talk to you again.
[inaudible] holy
cow.
You can see without care.
[inaudible]
to the phase.
The next good thing.
[inaudible]
uh,
[inaudible] now
[inaudible].